it's time for screen junkies movie bides
we're miles at hashtag owl nation
hashtag go hooligans it's all about
bowels what's going on guys some movie
fights live we're ready to do it we have
three awesome fighters sitting at the
movie fights tail ready to throw down
let's meet today's combatants first off
oh you know she's one of the hosts of FX
movie download she's a new mom I'm most
excited about yeah because I bet she's a
fantastic mom and will be a fantastic
mom okay I take all that back
Sasha pearl raver Sasha yes let's do
this thing I am feeling so confident
about one of my arguments
uh-huh and that's it so let's even have
it you know that's called playing possum
you're fine then ya know I've seen that
before and I've seen that before
alright we'll see what happens second he
is the only player in movie fights
history to win a complete shutout did
not allow his opponent to get a point
and he's one of the real rejects but
he's no reject when it comes to movie
fighting Greg Alba thanks for having me
again how I love I honestly was thinking
about it today I am I get nervous when I
come in here because I realize I don't
feel like I'm amongst my peers when I'm
here I am such a fan of the whole screen
junkies universe Wow so it was like
clicking in my head today that's why I
get nervous when I show up to movie it's
a mutual admiration society because we
think you're fantastic and you've come
in here and put the smack down so you
also can't live for the good and Sasha
she's an intimidating fighter and and
stacy is a really good friend of mine
we are really good friends
speaking of our last combatant at the
table you know from the Schmo down and
six degrees of feature-film Stacy Howard
what's up guys I feel confident all
three of my questions are going to be
utter failures I'm super nervous awesome
I didn't know you guys were friends so
there could be like a whole
behind-the-scenes team situation with
the steel chair or something by the way
this this does not count for points but
Stacy I'm electing you best t-shirt oh
wow with the flowers oh man I had to
bring it today this was like 47 dollars
at amoeba but I bought it it's for
screen junkies Wow yeah amoeba man thank
you for going the extra mile Dan Merle
would be jealous of your jaw shirt I
think Josh shirt today I get always
wears a jaws shirt
speaking of Dan Murray Dan's not here
but we still got the Dan cam we do so
deciding today's fights is going to be
myself and those two fabulous
individuals first off we have our judge
and fact-checker lon Harris lon what up
Vita like a little bell ring but then it
didn't work it just went flat so I'm
here I hate it when bells do that
yeah there we go okay that time an angel
got its wings owl nation their total
nation that time an owl got its wings
yeah there we go she's gone off the
rails on glass head-on would you prefer
a hoot owl or a screech owl
what's a screech I feel yeah and the
voice of the people and sent from heaven
above it is Danielle Radford so Davies
Danielle so myself and lon will be
weighing in with our opinions on the
first three questions and you will be
coming through with the people's vote
please explain how that works so the way
this works that there are a lot of
really fun polls and things on the
Twitter please join those is our amazing
the only polls that count for this is
the poll that is on the youtubes those
do not go up until opening arguments
have started and have finished because
these are based on the arguments not on
what movies you liked if you want
instructions about how to vote in those
polls they are down in the description
or you can ask us in the chat we are all
trying to be in there as much as we can
answering questions and those polls we
will read them every round the hut they
only count in the case of a tie and then
in case there is like a three-way tie I
have to do a thing which I hate and then
this breathes in the speed round I have
to be my own person which I hate but the
thing that I love is when you send me
other possible answers dankmemes
other great things on the Twitter and I
will be looking at those so please
please tag me fights live send me
additional answer send me memes send me
all the fun stuff I see as much as I can
and I really tried to like make sure
that we highlight each and every one it
is
yeah sick sick memes like for example if
you wanted to take all our faces and put
them on the bodies of our folks yes the
best heck yeah so one more time how our
game works there are three regular
around questions and then we go into the
speed round with the top two competitors
and
one can be up three out going into the
speed round and the the person who's
down has a chance to come back so it's
anybody's game unless it's correct and
then it's just great he did pitch a
shutout before okay lost the second time
guys we have no jte today we got Billy
biz in the booth so Billy Billy Billy
biz and I have a little catchphrase
before he drops that package I say Billy
biz roll that beautiful bean footage
Thank You Thor Thank You Billy by the
way that is a roll that beautiful bean
footage a commercial reference from
several years ago what great thank you
for all a knowing that reference check
all right question number one question
number one Kazuto mwah
all right news broke this week that
Marvel side characters will be getting
their own Disney streaming shows so we
asked which Marvel character that hasn't
had their own solo movie should get a
streaming show on Disney service first
question and we'll start with player
number one
Sasha okay well I obviously am really
excited about the tweets this is gonna
get me since Marvel can't give a female
lead a film lol supposedly we're having
we've got Captain Marvel blah blah blah
supposedly we're getting a black widow
blah blah blah you know what I want to
see I want to see an all-female show I
want any dudes that's what I want I want
them to totally do a female takeover and
we're going to take over to do these
streaming service now I was told I could
not use Lady liberators so I'm not gonna
reference that what I'm gonna say is we
get Valkyrie we get Tessa Thompson to
lead the charge now here's the thing
about the lady liberators comic that
came out in the 19 in 1970 it was
actually sort of a like a dig on
feminism
written by all men so I'm saying we take
it we usurp it and we put it back in
their faces so what you have is you've
got Valkyrie and she gets together an
all-female team we can get Black Widow
Captain Marvel we can get the Miss
marble we can get I mean bring in the
x-men we can get mystique in this thing
we can get a storm in this thing we can
do a whole situation and we can have
with each week a new person coming in
until we have an ultimate super team of
all chicks no dudes suck on Marvel a lot
it all right there you go
Sasha coming in guns blazing with
boundary
there's absolutely no way that's not
gonna get so many great comments you may
be right all right let's go to our chair
Greg all right I chose the most odd one
you could think of but I'm going with my
heart today back in August of 2016 a
little more than a year before Thor
Ragnarok came out the world met a man
named Daryl on the internet there was
the man Thor I could hear some people
laughing because they know who exactly
who I'm talking about
one long chuckle relax the man Thor let
me do my opening salvo be the man Thor
was rooming with when Captain America
Civil War went down Thor describes him
as an average sort of everyday guide had
an amicable relationship however Daryl
had to constantly deal with annoying
things such as Thor leaving his hammer
in the middle of the room or Thor
showing up at his workplace to earth or
insisting he could pay his half of the
rent with Asgardian currency then his
job moved in LA where the Grandmaster
ended up accepting his Craigslist ad for
a new roommate daryl is always
interacting with these unique
personalities from the MCU always tries
to be patient understanding he's a
straight face guy in these office like
comedies it's like a half-hour
single-camera sitcom in the vein of the
office with some superhero splicing and
ever since that debuted on YouTube we
got three of those videos people have
been wanting more Daryl it's hilarious
he developed a fan base from the
ultimate streaming service which is
YouTube and his adventures with these
people what's great about them is they
allow us to see what these
larger-than-life characters are like
when you interact with them in normal
everyday environments living through
Daryl we get to see the odd funny
personalities of these comic book
characters when they're not involved in
high-stakes plot so you know people say
thor ragnarok reinvented thor but no no
it was Darrell once that sketch came out
everyone got excited for a thor ragnarok
for that type of comedy and then
throwing in the Grand Master and every
week on this streaming service you could
have a new MCU character guest star
half-hour single comedy unlike anything
Marvel has done before and I'll wait for
the actual fight I have outlined a whole
show all right thank you Greg Stacey
what do you got well thank you for that
novella
it's got like five page Jarrell's the
back you know there are a lot of great
female Marvel characters that I would
love to flesh out and explore their
backstories but none so much as nebula
from guardians of the galaxy okay she
started as a villain in the first film
and then became kind of a reluctant ally
in volume - she's very clearly had a lot
of family issues and I would love to see
her backstory as a child fighting for
survival among the other amongst the
other children of Santos growing up with
a man that you hated in competition with
the sister that you wanted to love but
couldn't for fear of your life she has
such a heartbreaking history but she's
strong and she's smart and she's
learning to be more trusting of those
around her and not just look out for
house herself that can make for some
really great storyline so much of that
of Jessica Jones or daredevil who proven
themselves successful with Marvel fans
and critics so you know there are lots
of characters you can explore but she
would offer up the most material and the
most possibilities
all right fight it out you guys okay
first of all you talk about Darrell and
every single thing you said about
Darrell was how he interacted with other
characters yes that sue he's not
actually interesting Darrell is an
editor own people love Darrell he's the
funny Darrell like let's say we have a
standalone Darrell it's not just Darrell
and that's the point is that every way
to get a new MCU character right exactly
you're talking about a half-hour show
talking over each other guys I mean like
a two-minute sketch it's not because you
don't have a central character that
people are gonna get behind they're only
gonna be tuning in for stunt casting and
as anybody who watched on Google can
tell you it can't just be about this
night casting it has to be about gopher
well I'm glad you brought up about you
know and you think it might be a two
minute sketches I have outlined a whole
season for you guys
reasons why you want to show I actually
have no I haven't shown mine and I'll
shorten this I am made highlight points
here episode 1 where's Nick Fury bin so
in the first episode the first episode
is the first episode Darrell gets hired
to witness takes place a little bit
before infinity war he gets hired to
work at the avengers headquarters where
the office manager is Nick Fury furious
upset because he has been left out of a
lot of the superhero adventures as of
late because like he was at last summer
song was age of Ultron than the end
scene of infinity war so he's been kinda
been pushed back to the corner so he
starts spying on Darryl in the first
episode c'mon half hour like on his
comedy this first episode with Nick Fury
and he becomes suspicious of Darryl
because why is Thor rooming with Darryl
why does the Grand Master Luminara why
are these people of supernatural
abilities gravitated towards a man like
Darryl and then he realizes he could use
Darryl to his abandoned so in the second
episode we're only on episode here's why
I'm thinking that nebula is a little
better to waste an FAL curry it's really
hard for me to argue against you Sasha
because I love that character so much
but we did get a lot of her backstory
and thor ragnarok we actually saw um you
know interactions with her when she was
you know fighting against everything
with their other Valkyries and all the
tragedy that happened so we did get to
see a little bit of her her character
fleshed out what the nebula we haven't
seen any of that we've only been given
hints or had conversations and I think
she is the most compelling of everyone
in her character art could go from dark
to light learning and growing to falling
again that there's so many options was
what you said was you want to see her as
a child and then you reference jessica
jones and honestly a child version of
Jessica Jones is terrifying and you
can't really have children on set for
that long so yours production-wise is
very different
just tell a lien you can get a very
small woman's beauty we saw Brunhilde 's
backstory mm-hmm that means that the
audience is going in rooting for her
they already know that stuff we don't
have to do a whole bunch of backstory
stuff we can get straight into creating
female although no it's not that's my
every single thing a source material we
already know what's going on and what we
want to know is what's the next
adventure and I want to see Tessa
Thompson can do no wrong for me but to
see her leading a television show like
this where we get action where we get
comedy where we get all that stuff and
we can bring in like you're saying with
Darryl guest stars we can have other
people from the MC you can have an
all-female force and like you're saying
nebula we can go deeper into the
backstory we can go deeper into the
Valkyrie Rock strife anchor but it's
about creating a new super team it's
about creating new superheroes and
that's what we need for a streaming
service I think about sports for one
character though you're asking for an
ounce I'm saying without brain I'm
saying Valkyrie Brunhilde the Tessa
Thompson character is creating a new
league of superheroes because we don't
need the Avengers anymore we can now
have the Valkyrie and she is leading the
charge it's more like an alias thing I
think Valkyrie
I think Valkyrie and Thor Ragnarok has
too many similar sticks she's
essentially to me the female space
pirate version of Jack Sparrow after the
first Pirates of the Caribbean the Jack
Sparrow stuff got insanely old people
got bored of it it's point seven billion
dollars we disagree with you it's not
about the boss this is about when people
actually thought of Jack Sparrow no it's
the Jack Sparrow it's very old after a
while and I think she works better as a
supporting player as opposed just
wanting a lead
Thompson's a good actress but she's
barely in the thor ragnarok movie I went
through the movie last night you could
look up how much screen time out of a
two hour and 10 minute master or Tessa
Thompson is Valkyrie probably Tessa
Thompson that's still a huge supporting
character okay my point with that though
is Tessa Thompson in that movie I think
what makes her character effective she's
the kind of character that's more
effective in a supporting role she's the
kind of character that's more effective
when she's bouncing off of Thor other
than that I think her character is not
all of that entertaining when you really
think about it she got that bde that's
what she has see she's getting for
fighting my argument against what you
have with her let's go ahead and hit
some final thoughts Sasha go ahead and
roll this into your final thoughts with
Valkyrie you get pathos because we do
know her backstory you get all of this
amazing action and you get to create a
new league that can have different
characters that we haven't seen over and
over and over again and most importantly
Tessa Thompson went to Kevin Feige and
said I want to do an all-female Marvel
team-up and he said yes so let's not
just give the people what they want
let's give Kevin Feige what he wants all
right Thank You Sasha Greg take us to
your final thoughts I think of what
makes the emcee I think if you're gonna
do a Disney streaming service with these
shows you have to have something that
it's entirely unique I think if you
bring nebula who is kind of a OneNote
and like she's not really that
interesting of a character in the movies
people no one gets excited to see nebula
gomorrah's the interesting part to that
dynamic nebulas not interesting Valkyrie
herself I prefer her to be part of the
revenge or whatever threat calls that
team I think she works better in the
supporting character part I feel like
all those sticks would get old after a
while if you're watching the show and
too much exploration can diminish those
effective qualities and small doses I
think though if you want to introduce
Valkyrie you could introduce her to
episode three of my team Darryl show
where after the snap Valkyrie ends up
moving in with Darryl because Darryl
needs a new roommate because half of the
Avengers headquarters has been wiped out
and and Valkyrie was recommended by
or to live there so every episode with
my show though it would be something
entirely unique entirely different than
you've seen from any of the MCU
it would be a different genre splicing
and also you can have a new character of
the week cuz I think my favorite mode
some of these MCU movies are like when
the heroes are trying to pick up Thor's
hammer or when Loki and Thor are arguing
about brotherly things and Thor Ragnarok
those human moments is what you would
get in this show a chance to really
explored and I think on YouTube you saw
that people it's already kind of a
sizzle reel that's been tested of the
Darryl show we have like people wanted
more that's what people were demanding
after they want see Daryl in the MCU and
I think on a streaming service it's the
perfect format thanks Greg Stacey take
it home alright so there's nothing I
love more than a show about superheroes
where it's focused on a human with no
powers what I want for nebula is to see
how she grew up how she became the woman
she is and what she's developing into
you start with the first film with vol 1
you see her this villain she already has
a story arc she already has changed
grown and become even more a part of the
team in the second one so that shows you
that she can grow she is not one note a
show would give the opportunity to have
this strong complicated woman she's not
perfect it's not the Madonna or the
[ __ ] it's this woman that has the
chance to explore the entire galaxy and
really have you know an entire range of
emotions that go with the kind of
character that she is so that's what I
want a TV show for her Valkyrie is great
don't get me wrong but I think that
nebula we want us we haven't seen enough
of her and that's why she deserves her
own show doctor we have gotten a little
bit in our own film Stacey thank you so
much hoot hoot that's the end of round
one over one one no incorrect facts but
a couple facts that are sort of
interesting it was a single joke issue
of The Avengers number 83 and 1970 that
introduced the lady liberators they
brought them back in 2008 she hook
reformed the team briefly for Greg's
Darrell we know did survive the infinity
Wars now we have confirmation from
family
does currently appear as a regular
character on that guardians of the
galaxy animated series as for my pick
these wrong I liked all the pitches but
when it comes right down to it I feel
like two people pitched great Marvel
shows and one fighter pitched what
character should get a streaming show
which was actually the question so I had
to go on this one too Spacey I think she
the character would be deserves her own
show as opposed to sort of pitching what
would be another Valkyrie on that thank
you for going and making your pick right
there so I saw it a little bit
differently than you did so yeah I
thought great from my heart I know I'm
not gonna I mean Greg I thought you had
a really interesting answer until we
started hearing the episodes and they I
don't know what they be started to
become less compelling to me but I
didn't really hear from Sasha and Stacy
what your shows would look like and what
an episode might feel like what and I
didn't have an idea for the show so as
far as the show that seemed to have the
most legs and the most vision to me it
was Greg well the Darryl show I can walk
off the stage right now
yeah even though yeah I was I was
waiting for because I love those
characters but I just I didn't hear
enough about what the show would be and
that even though it wasn't perfect
no Stacey won for Greg
Daniel Radford filtering all right we're
looking at the polls we have at 51%
Darryl 25% at 23% we had nebula he and
other socials y'all had a lot of really
good ideas Peggy Carter called um Moon
Knight a lot of people like hardcore for
hawkeye some of the great tweets I saw
that pepper
we had Kingdom Commander Turk from the
Netflix shows I just want to see this
guy try to live his life when
superheroes keep popping in and out I
would watch that show I'm an act Buck
Bunker on Twitter says I want a serious
that is just the least explaining
Avengers battles for 11 minutes of peace
you are not wrong also a lot of people
who suggested an ex-con series which I
thought would be so much fun
at road Raider 3 says you know what I
want to see Lady SIF and the Warriors
three of a TV show when Thor is out
doing his Avenger thing imagine SIF
stepping up and leading the Warriors on
epic adventures with the cool mythical
world of Asgard in the background oh and
then at Eragon many to says I think I
want to see the Ravagers leaders and
what that series would look like from
the og so he was just alone and then
which other yeah how about yeah very
cool Thank You Danielle
Sasha I love that you made a love book
reference
yes classic stuff I think you know
Valkyrie I would love to see a Valkyrie
TV show I just had a little trouble
wrapping my head around that okay yeah
okay so I only have one I feel good I
think Valkyrie shows up in Durocher good
choice John see Riley's character is
like and Everybody Loves Raymond you
know laugh track comedy with his little
alien family and like his
mother-in-law's like I guess Macondo
would be a funny episode too I love you
sweetie I love me some rule I would like
to see Steve Rubell in the Marvel
Universe okay question number two the
house with a clock and its walls opens
this weekend we ask what's the best
scary movie for kids what is the best
scary movie for kids and we'll start
with player number two since it's
question number two Greg yeah I grew up
on horror movies since I was a little
kid was never really censored thanks mom
and dad and I think I actually think
though it's okay for kids to watch scary
movies and in some ways I actually feel
like they should because being a child
is a scary endeavor life itself is
pretty scary so as much as I want
children to watch you know movies where
everything is sunshine and rainbows
I think scary movies if you show them
the right one can help children deal
with fear in a safe environment and with
the right movie being courage to face
and overcome fear that's why I'm
choosing the human scent up now I'm
choosing Peter Norman today
para Norman's my choice one reason I
really love this movie is because before
it even gets too spooky paranormal stuff
there's the real life for late ability
of being in Norman shoes things that
create real life fear such as bullying
and also and I think if you're not even
severely bullying you can you can
identify what Norman in terms of you
know feeling didn't you take my water
feeling lonely or misunderstood oh well
I'm choking on my cookie from earlier
and also to Norman's exposed like adult
real life problems in the movie so even
before it gets like paranormal stuff
it's already kind of scary for his life
so you get the strong modern
identification and it's just like
animated fun movie mixed in with moments
that are honestly actually scary I think
out of my movies mine actually has the
horror element throughout the whole
thing and it's elements that truly help
to serve the character but also help
enhance the themes that kids should walk
away from with this movie so you know
this movie won't traumatize your kid but
it encourages to pretend it encourages
kids to not pretend that fear doesn't
exist acknowledge it process that even
embrace it and let it go so we can be
prepared for whatever else comes next
like Norman's grandma says there's
nothing wrong with being scared as long
as you don't let it change who you are
alright thank you Greg Stacey all right
you know kids are tricky because they
have to hold the attention of the kiddos
but also be entertaining for the parents
as well you have to have that balance of
sophomoric humor in that highbrow double
entendre wing to the parents in the
audience so there's no movie that does
this better than the Addams Family these
ghoulish gargoyles are complete freaks
of nature aren't there to find death
there celebrating them a cop who'll
mungus didn't have an you know email in
her Wednesday that wanted to kill their
brother literally at its core a scary
movie for kids needs to have a message
okay so much like The Fast and the
Furious franchise this film is all about
family okay they stick together they
support each other they don't care what
the outside world thinks it's about
being yourself
however putrid that is you can't run
from or forget about who you are even in
the Bermuda Triangle it's hilarious it's
gross it's
Gary it's perfect Adams family Thank You
Stacey
Sasha alright so the question here is
what is the best scary movie for kids so
let's just start with talking about best
I want to talk about a movie that was
one of the 25 that was first inducted
into the national registry along with
Casablanca Citizen Kane Star Wars I want
to talk about a movie that has Oscars
for Best Song best score was nominated
for Best Picture but lost what did it
lose to Gone with the Wind
we're talking about the one the only The
Wizard of Oz now we know this movie is
incredible
this movie is iconic but let's talk
about why it is also scary AAF okay two
words for you people flying monkeys
flying monkeys will give you nightmares
forever let's also talk about the creepy
Wicked Witch is like hey we get you my
pretty and your little dog too we all
know you can't hurt the dog that isn't
rule number one you do not also hurt the
dog you've got death by crushing you've
got a murder that is celebrated by
singing Little People you've got a
melting which a scarecrow that we come
to love getting threatened with fire
you've got those horrible apple trees
that come to life and a soul you and
then throw apples in your face and
supposedly we've got a munchkin that
hung himself to death because he was low
mourn and the back of one of the scenes
along happy overgrown fun part is scary
scary scary scary it is so scary in fact
that the MPAA had to revoke its G rating
when they released it and put it out as
PG because they were like me there was
also a fun fact the Scarecrow Cowardly
Lion and the Tin Man along with the
Wicked Witch were so frightening in
their costumes that they were not
allowed to eat in the MGM lunchroom
because they were scaring the workers
they had to go eat in their dressing
room you've got a main character who's
func flung far from home I was killed by
a tornado and then goes after this
horrible like floating head man who is
the wizard who is evil and scary but
also like mean and like ah it's
terrifying there's a reason that people
watch that movie on drugs because they
there is so much darkness in that movie
so much darkness so not only is it the
best it's also the scariest all right
fight it out you guys
there's no denying that wizard is an
iconic movie there's no denying that at
all but I think it's fear elements are
not the takeaway of the movie I think
the fear elements are intermittent
throughout the scary moments it's like I
feel like there's so many movies that
have a scary element here or there but
that doesn't mean the tone of the movie
deals with horror the tone of the movie
deals with fear ParaNorman is a movie
where the entire aesthetic is a horror
movie that movie gets scary once we go
into the woods and once the witch scene
looks like that - truly the scariest
part of it that scariest part - if
you're gonna bring up like a there are
better movies that you could have fought
for like a-- like why aren't you
fighting Coraline
I chose ParaNorman because that's where
my heart's a fantastic movie it's a
great movie I don't know that it's a
kids movie it's not something that you
watch 10 11 12 and it's PG if you're
talking about element mine's animated
yours is like real life and you're
talking about these out my elements I
also have the horror elements of zombies
and ghosts and ghouls and even at the
very beginning Norman is a kid who's has
this traumatizing lifestyle but he
escapes through horror movies and sees
the good that can come from embracing
your fear and letting go of it it sounds
kind of oscillating mine is uplifting
mine is couched in something that is
normal something that were celebrating
this is it is creepy it is terrifying
but I mean I love Addams Family but I
feel like Addams family shouldn't even
be in the car my sauce is a comedy yours
is a one-liner comedy goblins and ghouls
and pail people and savory balls and
graves
I mean you know Gigi's not teen comedy
actually now it's children
but it's the tone and the vibe in which
you no one walks away from Adams family
being like that was some scary stuff for
me thinking about how silly it 1 or if
you go to Rotten Tomatoes consensus it
says right there that it's a skin it
also has scary scenes what it says lots
I seriously want I want you to go onto
the socials and see if people did not
have more scary children funny is in
parentheses guys children don't want to
be scared and dudes when they watch
these films they want to learn a great
lesson they want to laugh they want to
cry they want to have fun with their
parents and have those lovely
governments to it those horrid and
macabre elements to it Adams family is
the only one that really does that out
of the three that we have to choose from
there's no no way do you know what
Steven Spielberg told Eli Roth for the
house with that what are the Tuttle is
he said naked scary kids kids like being
scared this is the guy who created
amylin who created gremlins and
everything like help produce gremlins
and all those things because kids like
actually feeling scared like going back
to like I'm sorry but his family's just
not a scary movie there's nothing in
there that makes you I also I also think
that it's like I think the kids in the
movie the only two kids it's like very
mean-spirited humor and I I feel like if
you watch the movie now you're gonna
show it to a kin now you gonna show them
a movie that encourages stuff like
anti-bullying and I'm like what I love
about paranormal sallying like when
you've got the Wicked Witch who's so
evil and does Dorothy's kind of a dick
in that movie
shows up the house like crashes on
someone like it cracks up someone kills
like when you think of The Wizard of Oz
what does everyone call back to they go
back to the music the production design
you saw sky blackened with flying
monkeys you would be freaked out
obviously this is a personal thing for
me but yes I'm telling you this is
terrifying so the Caribbean has like
skeletons skeletons and dead people but
no moves like that's a scary movie
that's a horror element but it doesn't
make it a scary thing and also the scary
stuff in it doesn't help enhance the
themes or team or help with any of the
lessons that's scary right go ahead and
roll this into your final thoughts I
think ParaNorman simply the best choice
because it's the best scary film for
kids it's the only one that it actually
has that aesthetic throughout it tells a
nuanced story about fear and our
responses to it and about understanding
it it's all about that and there's some
very powerful relevant messages that are
so necessary for kids to hear today and
beyond life lessons you know that's
because this is movie fights it's also a
great gateway into other horror movies
the kids obsessed with horror movies and
watching stuff about zombies that comes
into play witchcraft you get all kinds
of elements the aesthetic there's some
real scares in that movie Wizard of Oz
to me is a musical with an occasional
scary moment depending on how you look
at it Adams family is a wacky comedy
with some really bad one-liners
ParaNorman is an actual horror movie
that was tailored for children hence the
best thank you Greg Stacey I really
don't consider like an animated film or
no actually I'm a musical to be a true
horror film The Addams Family has core
elements about family about being
yourself about not you know going into
the norm so this film is really has else
for the entire family that anyone can
watch so if you want a family
a family kids scary movie this is what
you're gonna show your kids you're not
gonna have them beat terrified by
monkeys or watch an animated film that
really doesn't count as a horse in my
opinion you want it to be something that
everyone's gonna enjoy and that's why I
pick Adams family all right
scary Thank You Stacey background to
such a poor waiver I feel like if you
want to pick a movie that everybody's
gonna like you go for the movie that is
the number 10 on afi's 100 best films of
all time list I feel like if you want to
teach children a lesson the scariest
thing to a child is being away from
everything they love and everybody who
they know so if you want to really scare
a kid show them the Wizard of Oz because
you are literally ripping them away from
home and putting them in a world that
they don't know and you don't want to
just show a child a horror movie you
want to be able to show them something
that they can learn from that yes they
can be scared by that they can also
learn a lesson which is home was always
right here you click your heroes two
times and you sing somewhere over the
rainbow because you get the fear but you
also get knowing that you can go back
home again and everything can be okay
and I think that's incredibly important
and if we're just talking about best
films not only is this film incredibly
frightening but it is also a conic is
one of the best films that has ever been
made and that is in arguable hoot hoot
that's the end of round two into your
answer while your decision is grouted
one fact I do need to check this is it's
a urban legend but one that has been
frequently debunked a munchkin did not
hang themselves on the straightedge
Snopes has the proof they had not even
yet the bugs have not arrived on set
when they stop that scene there's no way
it's a dead one I salute you
totally clean fight everybody good picks
I like all three of these movies very
much but I thought I thought there was
one clear winner
I think Sasha made a great argument for
why The Wizard of Oz is a great movie
but I found Greg's argument pretty
convincing that it's a great movie that
you remember a lot of elements from not
necessarily just the scary stuff
although flying monkeys did really scare
me as a kid I think you made a great
argument for why it's like a fun
memorable comedy but I wasn't really
sold on it being a scary movie I think
Greg did a really great job of
describing why ParaNorman is both a
great movie for kids and also a great
scary movie in its own right I go to
Fred okay so that's a 1 for Greg yeah I
saw it a little bit differently here you
and me just can't agree so yes
Stacy I appreciate your love for the
Addams Family but I don't baby but I
mean I don't know about that knock again
spalpeen
also just your argument about it being
like kind of like more of a
four-quadrant movie or appealing to you
know kids and adults I feel like it
wasn't quite germane to this question so
for me it came down to Greg and Sasha
and yeah as I thought Greg just your
opening salvo and everything you said
were it was excellent but then you know
I was listening to Sasha and I'm talking
about her last Sonu
it is scary those flying monkeys are
scary that Wicked Witch of the West when
they when they saw us in the field
because of the poppies when you're a kid
there are scary as heck scenes and
taking the both parts of the question
the best scary movie for kids and we
didn't qualify the age range or anything
I think Wizard of Oz ticks those boxes
the most for me I'm going Wizard of Oz
we are locked up at to the side for some
reason again my cart is not loading but
as of right now at 68% we've got
ParaNorman on the 21% Wizard of Oz and
Adams family coming in at 10:00 my
roommate John really helped me out a lot
gremlins monster second choice probably
people were really cranky oh did not
pick gremlins Return to Oz yeah we're
talking about Return to Oz the other day
writing stuff yeah no thank you
Nightmare on Elm Street which is the
reason why because when I was younger
Freddy was definitely a good fit Freddy
tell your mom and dad anyway oh my
number and you can take my buzz Esther
around like movie number four which is
when he ate the pizza where it was
people's heads uh reason why I have to
read books or watch something nice when
I eat because I didn't eat for a week as
a kid and I was like four is where your
old Teddy I refused to eat because my
goodness you're gonna eat Freddie so
some other
TJX Monster Squad at movie freud's movie
monsters are you afraid the dark movie
came up a lot of people had some really
interesting et arguments that you should
look up Russia government also got
okay people were real cranky other than
cheese gremlins yeah which one I was
hidden you're waiting for Ernest scared
stupid James and giant peach the Rhino
human Senate okay okay there's some game
to be played so going into round number
three it is Greg to Stacy and Sasha
looking to get on the board
all right here is question number three
I'll throw this round so lots of folks
are talking about the craziness that is
NIC cages new movie Mandy okay so we ask
what horror movie villain would be most
improved if they were played by Nicolas
Cage and it's question three we'll start
with player three Stacey all right
Nicolas Cage has delivered some of the
greatest lines in film history put the
bunny back in the box
you know I could eat a peach for hours
he is simply recited the alphabet but
he's never played like a monster you
know not anything that's truly gross
he's pretty much always been the lead
guy they can't really allow him to look
unattractive in those roles just imagine
the possibilities of Nicolas Cage as
penny wise in it there isn't just one
face to this villain this would allow
the cage master to explore multiple
interpretations of things that scare
kids dozens of creatures the accents the
hairstyles it could be like his entire
film career on display in one movie he
would have so much fun while all the
wild things that he could be as penny
wise and when Nicolas Cage has been in a
movie the audience has fun watching him
all right Thank You Stacey penny wise
back over around to Sasha all right I'm
glad you brought up fun because you're
right when Nicholas Cage has fun we all
have fun but for me what I was thinking
about is movie that really deserves
villain and that is silence and lamps no
I am NOT talking about Hannibal Lecter
his handle after is a perfect villain
I'm talking about Buffalo Bill when
people watch Silence of the Lambs they
only talk about Anthony Hopkins they
only talk about Hannibal Lecter they
don't talk about Ted Levine's portrayal
it's almost become this scene in
particular it's almost like a joke it's
a gift him dancing around with his
kimono and mangina saying I'd blank me
like that is it's not something that
people fear it's something that they
kind of laugh at and what I want to see
is the Nicolas Cage version of him
dancing around doing this whole thing I
think it would be the true embodiment of
cage which is actual crazy because Ted
Levine though he is a great actor
doesn't bring real crazy Nicolas Cage
always brings real crazy and that's what
we need we need true terrifying lune
enos that Ted Levine never brought so we
have a real foil in Silence of the Lambs
not just it puts lotion in the basket or
gets the hose because that is literally
a joke it's become a gag and if Nicholas
Cage had done it nobody would be
laughing all right Thank You Sasha Gregg
fundraiser makes you said it did you
just feel like you're pulsed right my
choice is The Nightmare on Elm Street
not the original Robert Englund I'm
talking about the 2010 remake the one
that star Jackie Earle Haley
this one we had a lot of anticipation
because it was possible to fathom a
modern visual take on Freddy Krueger
what we got was essential you know
direct sometimes shot-for-shot remake of
the original except for one thing that
had no soul and was completely bland
devoid of personality I agree on all the
positives you guys are saying about what
Nicholas Cage would bring to the role
when he really commits to the crazy Nic
Cage and this could have elevated it
well we got what Jackie Earle Haley was
a very bland kind of like the mission of
what he did with Rorschach in Watchmen
what you needed was someone who could
match the quality of the insane devilish
personality that Robert
and brought to the role of Freddy
Krueger and this of this movie like it
while the movies not that good the
question is about what who would improve
the movie what would improve it your I
feel like your guys's picks these are
great movies no one's complained about
they should have been recast or whatever
they're fantastic films Nightmare on Elm
Street could have at least been an
entertaining good time but the one thing
they had to get right the one thing
which is casting a memorable Freddy
Krueger and Nic Cage easily with his
craziness would have been able to match
the heights of Robert Englund absolutely
write it out absolutely not are you
kidding me nobody wanted that remake it
never would have done what it needed to
do and because Robert Englund is so
intrinsic to that part you can't replace
him if you put Nicolas Cage in that part
it becomes a joke you and I both know
that what Nicolas Cage in anything it's
fun of it's not a joke now I mean tenth
evene is perfect in them joke people
it's a meme it's a gift
91 whatever it was that was a terrifying
portrayal of everyone's worst fear of
being kidnapped you're trying to tell me
that one that he kidnapped Katherine and
shoved her into that van and beat the SH
I T out of her you weren't horrified
they're trying to tell me when she was I
was like looking down that well at her
horn portrayed people you know with any
kind of mental illness as this like
really over-the-top crazy character but
he doesn't in such a way where you
believe this man believes what he's
doing is right and that he needs
the thing is when he was drinking
himself to death and he was like no this
is what I deserve for my problem is it's
not going to improve the film no no
one's really complained about Ted Levine
and science of the people more than they
do Hannibal Lecter I do that mangina
thinks of my girlfriend every single day
Stacy I want to hear a little bit more
about why Nicolas Cage would improve
what stars car did and anyone has penny
wise in it instead of Tim Curley in the
you know original miniseries he rolls
have something lacking in the kid the
actors and the characters that they
tried to put penny wise in so Nicolas
Cage would have brought his intensity
his strength his insane crazy eyes to
any of the penny wise manifestations
that would have come about they had like
snakes and diseased people and all kinds
of crazy crazy stuff Nicolas Cage is the
only actor that could really take penny
wise and make him horrifying and not
make each of these weird interpretations
you know a joke to kids I mean there's
casting it all you would see is Nicolas
Cage brilliant in that part and
skarsgård was so great but he had to
redefine after such a great stamp that
Tim Curry put on it you get it's kind of
comparable for me what Heath Ledger did
after following up Jack Nicholson with
the Joker they feel like if you watch
Bill skarsgård in an interview and then
you watch a it's like different people
and what happens when we have a problem
with casting the internet makes a stupid
petition to recast them it too is coming
out everyone's jacked up about it
no one's like recast penny wise I hated
him everyone loves him he's like one of
the biggest haul the week everyone loves
you know
but here's my issue with the Freddy
Krueger thing yes ma'am that was not the
only issue with that movie that whole
movie has to be redone it's not just you
put in a different Freddy Krueger in you
of a better movie you need entirely
different set pieces you need a
different writer you need a different
improving the movie is an Oscar nominee
was absolutely terrifying who is weird
looking he was perfect casting for
Freddy Krueger he was perfect God no he
didn't even try it's not true he was
trying to do a quieter more sovereign
England is so intrinsic to the part just
put Robert Englund back in it the thing
about Ted Levine is you guys may think
that he's iconic I guarantee you if you
asked the internet which weekend most
people think about the Anthony Hopkins
part about the Jodie Foster part it's
Ted Levine is not a name that rolls off
the tongue when people talk about
Buffalo Bill it is a side tertiary
situation it comes from our fear of
being taken it comes from what we imbue
that character with but he as an actor
did nothing to make it truly iconic and
I think because I'm not talking about
crazy wacky Nikaido nothing to your
final thoughts I am talking about the
Nick Cage who is an Oscar nominee I am
talking about Nick Cage who can
literally take his face off and it can
be something that you remember forever I
want to see him say hi Bob I'm not my
sister's children but I think that what
you have here is that movie is this
close to perfect that movie is brilliant
beyond measure and can be re watched
over and over and over again I'm asking
for the one thing that takes it because
if you have seen Andy it's an incredible
film and she's bonkers in it and what we
need is true bonkers not actor playing
bonkers Thank You Sasha Greg final
thoughts I think both of your films are
already near perfect in terms of the
entire thing if the your your if the
villains in your movies did not work the
movies
wouldn't work it's that simple but those
movies are very highly regarded by
audiences critics your move you want a
bunch of awards why I mean both of your
movies are quoted so much because of how
effective those roles are Ted Levine
what I love about that is with Ted
Levine you don't see Ted Levine all you
remember is Buffalo Bill it's effective
at best Nic Cage might be entertaining
but I would still only see Nicolas Cage
with your roles I only see the
characters it would by no means to go
back to the question improve the film it
would weaken it because as much as even
in Mandy when he is crazy he's doing
good but I still only see Nicolas Cage
and I'm watching that movie the
questions about improving Nightmare on
Elm Street the one thing they had to get
right the main thing to improve the
movie was a crazy memorable performance
of the guy playing Freddy Krueger all
the Nic Cage isms whatever would have
elevated majority of that film and would
have made the would have made the
quality of Silence of the Lambs or it no
wouldn't have but it would have improved
it and at least made it enjoyable to
watch I feel like putting an occasion
there would weaken the film's not
improve them
thank you Greg Stacey I disagree 100%
that Nicolas Cage is portrayal opinion
wise would weaken it bill skarsgård is a
great actor I love him on other shows
like Hemlock Grove on Netflix and stuff
like that and he has it comes from a
great actor you know family but if you
want to take Nicolas Cage and give him
something to do you want to give them
multiple facets of a character you want
to have him go highs and lows in a film
you want to have you know different
costumes different hairstyles you want
to see everything that he has to offer
so if you want to put him in a role that
he can improve and really show
everything he's got that's penny wise
that's multiple characters that he could
play multiple manifestations of
something that strikes fear in all of us
not just one character it is really the
only film from these options that gives
him that that really loves him show his
range if you have Nicolas Cage you want
him to be the most Nicolas Cage ek
things personally
Hey okay all right - to who that's the
end of the round I just got caught up in
that cage and a cage uncaged yeah man
what character needs to get caged any
facts to check no facts to check get
totally cleaned around as far as I could
tell Ted what means greatest buffalo
bill that's the only fact
so yeah this I really enjoyed hearing
everyone steaks and I love listening to
your movie opinions you guys and and it
gets me going hop in several times
because you guys are so fun to listen to
and yeah I was in on this but um yeah to
me it came down to the question it
wouldn't all of yours would be fun to
see I love to see cage to the scenery
the man can hug the man has a very
special thing going yeah the movie that
needed to be improved
it is Nightmare on Elm Street the remake
Lavigne he you need him to be a little
bit more understated than Hannibal
Lecter that was his movie to take for a
joyride Anthony Hopkins and yeah Bill
skarsgård I mean he scared me it was fun
that that scene in the garage where
they're watching the films where they're
watching that the slideshow yikes I've
jumped out of my seat and crapped my
pants uh figuratively so yeah I got it
I gotta go with Nic Cage as Freddy
Krueger sign me up that would take that
movie somehow to the next level long
yeah but two of the answers didn't
really answer the question I don't know
how you really improve that I knew it or
Silence of the Lambs they're both so
great so I feel like those Sacha and
Stacy had great arguments they really
started like way behind the eight ball
on this one just by picking great movies
that it's hard to improve on Greg picked
a terrible movie and I have to agree
that yeah Jackie Earle Haley swap him
out with Cage that movie gets a lot
better even if it's still kind of not
great so I go with Greg Greg you get the
point you're up three O gonna destiny
everybody online well now that I finally
figured out I had to download Chrome
because you guys already knew I just
learned how to use an apple computer
laptop like two months ago so I'm behind
I'm not great but yeah 57% went for
Freddy Krueger
it was 24% for Buffalo Bill 18% for
penny wise some other notables babadook
another one I was not able to look at as
a child
absolutely for it might be me of my
horrible thing and then at 3,000 Elinor
on Twitter said Nic Cage could have
really handed up a Seth Brundle as the
fly that movie just begged for some Kade
style overacting I mean look we all we
all love the movie but and and we all
love the Goldblum but man I would like
to see the Hudson it version starring
Nick Cage my second you can go over the
top Eon it's always like a Ghost Rider
transformation was De Niro as
Frankenstein interesting or what about I
mean it's perplexing Nick what about as
Lex Luthor in battle
okay so it's tiebreaker time you all
because we got to see which of these
ladies will be facing Gregg in the feed
round
so here are the rules for the tiebreaker
works basically like the speed around I
will ask the question whoever answers
first we'll get to elaborate on their
answer first and you'll each get 20
seconds 20 seconds and then 10 second
rebuttal ten second rebuttal
Danielle no more polls for you you
arguing us your own opinions which are
amazing but you don't like alright
ladies y'all ready yeah let's do it
y'all ready for that we got a new
trailer for Ralph breaks the Internet
today what internet character or
personality should Ralph and vanellope
visit tinder it's not a character this
time yeah
wreck-it Ralph is traveling on the
information superhighway where or who
should he visit okay who should wreck-it
Ralph visit when he hits the Internet oh
gosh um I'm gonna say Twitter your
Twitter you know we got Twitter and so
Sasha your 20 seconds begin whenever you
speak in my version of this what you
have is they're trying to get to a
single lady I'm not sure who that lady
is quite yet but you know she's on
tinder and they keep getting swiped they
keep getting spiced they keep getting
that left and they're just like no ain't
me with that right I need that match
that match I mean how great would it be
for Penelope to be like no here's the
things that you have to love about me
and wreck-it Ralph who deserves so much
love just try and try and try and
they're just getting the laughs in it
but sings off time there are so many
toxic messages and threads on Twitter
that their visit to it can be
discovering what true Manatee what
humanity truly is and has about itself
and trying to improve it by finding all
these weird niche memes and all these
like the horrible Nazi people and just
trying to take them all down and trying
to show everyone so apparently we have a
new scariest children's news is we've
got the Disney Princesses in Ralph's
reach the Internet let's have him get on
that Twitter tinder and try to swipe it
right to get it we need Twitter needs to
be improved okay we need something to
help out the my favorite messaging app
and my favorite information app where I
get all my news someone needs to go in
there and make it right and that is
their mission goal time all right
Danielle who is moving on yeah this was
a fantastic fight both really good
arguments for me I think for this round
I have to go with Sasha I agree with you
on that I think Sasha just had the
easier to wrap your head around kind of
that would be fun to see wreck-it Ralph
building his profile and swipe swipe
swipe that was a great argument but
[Applause]
doing the single ladies can we get a
shot of them doing the single ladies you
did not score points but no but you won
the hearts of the internet and you
really came with some great answers
thank you thank you
all right Greg okay I saved my I say my
snack for when I lost last yeah all
right so we are in the speed round here
and tough man guys the speed round works
just like the question we just had our
tiebreaker I'll ask the question first
person to answer and we'll go first 20
seconds 20 seconds then 10 second
rebuttal 10 second rebuttal and this is
kind of crazy but it's already game
point
if Greg gets this the day Sasha needs
this to keep the game going middle I
keep it alive all right here we go
all right question number one in the
speed round Space Jam 2 is happening
with LeBron the king with Ryan Coogler
producing what non Looney Tunes animated
characters should also join Space Jam
what non Looney Tunes animated character
should also draw a straight add animated
yes Ralph
like be like the recce guy Ralph Ralph
is he replacing Bugs Bunny no in
addition in addition we're gonna have
Roger Rabbit Roger Rabbit that's a good
choice okay Greg 20 seconds begin when
you speak now Ralph already loves to
play games that's the whole thing about
wreck-it Ralph and he would have such a
good time mean he's always just trying
to get along with everyone watching him
interact with Bugs Bunny and everyone
he's already transporting around
different games in different worlds it
wouldn't be out of the realm to see him
in the Looney Tunes world and have a
different kind of animation mixed in
with the original classic Looney Tunes
animation would be such a blast and John
Siever the thing about Roger Rabbit is
we've already seen him interact with
humans so it won't be as feel too far to
for us to like get that and what I see
is you got Bugs Bunny and then his crazy
wacky cousin Roger Rabbit shows up and
now the guy save the rec center and
they're gonna have to play the ultimate
game Michael Jordan and LeBron James and
that's something that we want to see I
mean I'm very sad to say that you know
Roger probably I think your idea about
the game is a lot more interesting than
actually having Roger Rabbit Roger
rabbits not relevant anymore and I think
you're gonna put a character in there
you're gonna want to sell this to kids
and kids know who Ralph is a lot of kids
might not even know who Roger Rabbit is
you want to talk about relevant Space
Jam is relevant
Roger Rabbit is eternal Roger Rabbit is
forever Roger Rabbit makes everything
better
you get him Bugs Bunny LeBron MJ that's
a good movie Darrell is time
one errors and lay it on us what do you
think both really good arguments I think
both of these characters would be fun to
see in the movie both fighters scored
some good points but ultimately I like
Sasha's point about we've seen Roger in
this sort of human animated world before
and kind of bouncing him off a Bugs
Bunny character he's already met I'm
going Sasha yeah I got to agree with you
there lon I thought Sasha laid out just
a better blueprint on how Roger would
fit into the movie and yeah Greg yeah
wreck-it Ralph likes to have fun and
play games Roger Rabbit another dance we
should make mon Dieu we found a new
screen junkies show all right Sasha you
are on the board nicely done here is
question number two of the speed round
Lucasfilm has announced that it will
slow down production on Star Wars movies
what's another franchise that should
pump the brakes
Oh Stacey hasn't the conjuring franchise
conjuring from Greg Sasha
once again this is game point oh god I
hate this okay so you're going to
conjuring I'm gonna say another
franchise that you pump the brakes it
breaks my heart but I'm gonna say the
fast in the Furious okay The Fast and
the Furious favor franchise The Fast and
the Furious please don't quote me on
this anything okay Greg you spoke first
for the conjuring 20 seconds again when
you speak now it's a great moment in
sports yeah have you guys seen the nun
wasn't that good of a movie and the nut
itself if you look at the box-office
performance of that film you would see
that it didn't hold well the second
weekend because of how terrible it is
and the conjuring has a great potential
it has this universe and it's one of the
few universes outside of Marvel that's
working but if you start doing what Star
Wars is doing it trying to catch up with
Marvel or follow the paths of DC you're
gonna start ruining the quality okay
which one do you say again okay The Fast
and Furious is my favorite franchise of
all time but I'm gonna be honest eight
sucked and we already know we have nine
and ten coming up and I feel like
they're making so many missteps we don't
need more movies with which have an
exact date the Condrey ins only have
three movies we have had seven fantastic
Fast & Furious movies the eight one went
off a cliff we need to take our time to
do a perfect beautiful Fast & Furious
movie Justin Lin we need Vin Diesel to
get off of his rock hatred the concert
has had a five movies it whenever they
debut a prequel it's not good it's
terrible fast and furious everyone's
excited for Hobbs and Shaw everyone
wants to see that movie I want to see
that movie fate of furious was actually
really fun I really enjoyed the hell out
of it when you get into a situation like
Hobbs in shower you've got spin-offs
where you have two movies that have
released it's already established you
end up doing fast work not good work
I want it good I don't care how long it
takes I just want my franchise to be the
perfect franchise that it is all right
Stacy what was your aunt's are gonna be
oh gosh The Terminator
let's just hold on bird what are you
thinking these were amazing arguments a
well everyone is excited for Hobbs and
Shah that was the argument I was looking
for from Gregg and then when Sasha said
the thing about the the dates and
spin-offs needed they're doing fast work
and not good work that was a great
counter what more do you want for me I
have to fix Asha Harris you know
actually I was going for Sasha but I
thought Greg had a pretty strong and
there he really did run through there
there have been five conjuring movies
the the prequels and the spin-offs don't
seem to be going that well but none just
came out it kind of didn't do is great
where as the eighth best appearance move
it was a global massive world I think I
go bring see that you said that so it's
it's one one this was an expertly argued
speed round question and yeah
just by the hair of she's on her own
just by one hair on her head Sasha
they're so painful I love the spirit so
much but it sucked man that was that was
a photo finish right there it's still
game point question number three guys
question number three Eddie Murphy
he plans to star in an update of grumpy
old men we should join him as the other
grumpy old man Murphy yeah
he's known for his double roles yeah
he's pumped it up before he's I'm saving
the Roger Rabbit for after workhorse
Danny Glover Danny okay we have Eddie
Murphy we have Danny Glover Sasha you
spoke first 20 seconds begin when you
speak now what I think about the Eddie
Murphy that I love which is the coming
to America Eddie Murphy which can
sometimes be the Klumps Eddie Murphy
which is Hercules Hercules doing it
himself
you cannot put him he's like a Patti
LaBelle he wants to sing over everyone
else you can't put him in with another
person and he Murphy needs to like let
his wings be free and fly he needs to do
his own thing if he's going to do grumpy
old man he is the men that is all the
eddie murphy you need and hopefully does
a song - yeah Nutty Professor - sucked
and the Norbit movie where he did that
same stick again was terrible that does
not work for Eddie Murphy anymore you
need to pair him up with someone who has
a different level what's always good
about these comedy movies is when you
have two different personalities two
different energy levels Danny Glover I
was watching Lethal Weapon again
recently his comedy chops in that whole
franchise is hysterical he is really
funny
have you seen Danny Glover in anything
recently no because the man doesn't have
it anymore I love him that he is old and
he's crotchety which works for the movie
but not if he can't remember his lines
what we need is we need Eddie Murphy to
return to the comedy gold that he always
gives us when he does the thing himself
I saw him and sorry to bother you very
recently he was absolutely really funny
in that movie people were cracking up in
the theaters watching that film Eddie
Murphy to return to that comedy format
that died there's a reason he doesn't do
that anymore because it's not funny
anymore
boy oh boy how about it lon Harris oh
man this one's really tough and actually
thought Such had gotten the kill shot
with the have you seen Danny Glover
funny rebound so I'm not I'm not really
fully sure I like both though because I
really do want to see anything I have to
disagree again and that was great though
where is Danny Glover he's kind of lost
it but the arguments for essentially he
didn't say this but essentially he's
arguing for the power of a straight man
which i think when you have someone with
the kinetic energy of a Eddie Murphy so
much different and then the fact that he
came back with that great sorry to
bother using um I have to go with Greg
yeah for those reasons as well I also
have to go
[Applause]
this is the first this is your second
fights big this is your first time here
with the slicked-back dude yeah cartel
look I love ya congratulations man you
you fought valiantly you made this thing
a game you both gave great antenna do
not make it easy on anybody lover I love
you by the way I was literally just
saying that to try to win and also with
the Fast and Furious I love you too Greg
Congrats on the victory go ahead and
plug some stuff tell us where you can
find you youtube.com slash the real
rejects I want to thank all the screen
junkies fans who have been hopping over
since I've been doing movie fights and
they've really been loving her videos
though people like don't really like
reaction videos I've been liking ours
because of our commentary so I really
appreciate all that feedback but I also
just wanted to say thank you guys again
the screen junkies like I don't I never
missed an episode of strange hunkies
news and that's I I first saw Sasha on
screen drug disease then movie fights
and I even watched like charting with
Dan I watched serious questions
like everything from screen junkies and
so to be here and be a fan and be here
for my third time is just amazing
something family you and guess what
sorry but you're part of the family now
she's a really cool event coming up
Stacy that is about it and Stacy let me
commend you again for just having
thoughtful excellent answers and really
bring it your I mean obviously anyone
who's seen the Schmo down knows that you
know your stuff but you really always a
pleasure to have you oh thank you guys
so much I love everyone at this table
I'm not Greg I'm gonna Sunday I'm truly
honored I do have a wonderful event
that's coming up that's gonna have some
really familiar faces in it so we are
screaming Star Trek's you the Wrath of
Khan on the moto bond Ricardo
montalban's theater Khan himself his
family still owns and operates it so it
is a very very special evening we're
gonna have special guests that include a
Scott mance tan Merle Mara no but Jason
Inman Ashley Robinson Jean Roca Robert
Myer Burnett all the best people you
guys are invited to Craig not you at
6:30 in the films gonna start at 8:00
p.m. there's gonna be themes drinks grab
yourself a Romulan ale you can have
where your costume for a contest we're
gonna have trivia and prizes you can get
your tickets at arena screen comm it's
gonna be a great special under the stars
with Star Trek fans of Hollywood the
light behind you but there's no better
than you than the multi bond they're
wonderful we're so excited to have it so
I hope everyone comes out we were
talking about scary scenes from with
four kids earlier at man when I saw Star
Trek 2 as a kid and that when they put
that earwig and the guys here
when you were listening who's gonna be
there like if you haven't gonna let my
friends who are the biggest Star Trek
fans I know you just listen though
that's awesome cuz I texted everyone and
I was like chill the screen oh Jesus
like a Star Trek fan and here we are
that's very cool and and what's the
website or where can they find tickets
again arena screen comm so it's October
5th doors open at 6:30 have some drinks
have some fun the film starts at 8:00
badass thank you so much Stacy
Sasha programmer I mean impressive speed
round always just impressive life you
know I'm so glad that Greg and I can
walk away from his friends regulations
on your baby thank you so much
congratulations on your win I'm just so
grateful that was scary my mom's
favorite movie you might miss twist it
Thank You Sasha always great to have you
thanks I where can they find you uh you
find me on Twitter and Instagram at
saucer Pearl River and every Friday on
FX hosting FX movie download heck yes
Juan Aris thank you for holding
[Laughter]
nobody's excited literally every week
it's long let them know where they can
find us it's only four letters it's easy
to type Daniel Radford thank you for
just being the voice of the people
please give some shoutouts solos etc yes
/ huge if you want to listen to me talk
about wrestles you can follow me or
either at my tights and fights you can
listen to the podcast
I've patreon now where we can talk and
be bugs and talk about wrestling some of
us can be very specific john mayhem if
you you're a screen junkies employee do
you remember when John's and harloff
teamed up
I don't remember last week oh that was
many moons ago I was hit by a bus I
don't remember but thank you all so much
and yeah this fun as always thank you
Danielle I'm Hal Rudnick you can find me
Hal Rudnick on all the social medias
Twitter Instagram etc yeah follow me
there let's talk movies and whatnot I
want to say Billy biz for stepping up
reduces the show but today he had to
jump in the booth because jte
get-well-soon my brother I hope you're
feeling better but Billy biz you've
stepped up big time and went off without
a hitch pretty much I don't know how it
isn't there
but I mean he goes but it was great out
here
and thanks for a great fight you guys
thank you for watching movie fights
we'll see you next week hashtag Allen
nation has to add Google against